what about you why are you down here I
wish I knew I spent countless years
trying to figure out a reason there is
no reason Eddie says the game rigged so
no one can leave my brother's proof of
that never did a bad thing in his life
he even died nobly stopping a
treacherous King from poisoning the
wrong stop it you're making me blush
Hayes's you two trapped down here and
that cannot stand the only way Evan will
get free as if we defeat Hades once and
for all name you've madani a very long
time surely must have something that can
help us I know this is a very dangerous
game you're playing there are those who
tried to overthrow Hades before I think
we spoke of her a book which had the
power to defeat him I tried to find it
myself but I'm not even sure what to
look for I think it's a storybook
storybook no age it would take more than
stories no no no no no no she's onto
something in our world there's a book
like this everything up there has a
version down here there has to be one in
the underworld there's a story in that
book about Hades we can learn his
weakness and exploit it alright if you
believe in is Killian I'm with you to
the end this fiend trapped me and
tortured you the day you push for sale
is too far is the day the mutiny begins
you